with supplements and rife be enough for H. Pylori, I think it's the question.
Um, typically yes. So, um, medical treatment of H. Pylori, H. Pylori is a bacteria in, uh, antibiotic.
Would be the treatment from a medical doctor for H. Pylori. Now they.
Made, uh, prescribed antibiotic unless you show positive in either a blood test or, um, some of a stool sample test or something like that.
Um, but for a medical standpoint, an antibiotic would be in order. If you're going to take an antibiotic, remember you always have to make sure that you take a probiotic with an antibiotic.
So it will, there's been studies showing that it cuts down on the side effects of the antibiotic when you take a probiotic with the antibiotic.
Um, but supplements on that will help kill that and using the right.
Usually are enough to help kill H. Pylori. Yes, usually are not to help kill it.
I mean, I, I don't recall having a person have to go and get an antibiotic for.
So, I mean, it may have happened. I just don't, I can't remember.
I don't think so.